s
seront et lancent ce soir leur
deuxième album nous dit Louis-
Philippe.
♪ Essayer de gagner sa vie
aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine, ♪
aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine ♪
- En Acadie, "Salebarbes"
est le nom donné à un filet
de pêche, mais "Salebarbe"
c'est aussi le nom d'un groupe
qui attrape dans ses filets
des rythmes acadiens et cajuns.
JONATHAN PAINCHAUD, membre
du groupe Salebarbes
- Presque toute notre oeuvre est
un cri d'amour pour l'Acadie,
à quelque part, c'est un peu
notre raison d'être.
♪ Moi j'après marcher
l'plancher ♪
- Après un premier album
récompensé par l'ADISQ,
"Salebarbes" revient avec
"Gin à l'eau salé". Un disque
enregistré en pleine pandémie
et à distance.
♪ Il y avait longtemps,
Longtemps, longtemps ♪
♪ Que j'avais baptisé
mon gin à l'eau salée ♪
JEAN-FRANÇOIS BREAU
Membre du groupe "Salebarbes"
- Quand je recevais, mettons,
un mix d'une des chansons, je me
suis vu danser devant la table
à café dans le salon en bobette
à 2 h 30 du matin, tout seul
dans le noir, puis à me dire :
OK, ça fait du bien.
♪♪♪
- Avec à bord les Madelinot Éloi
et Jonathan Painchaud et les
Néo-Brunswickois, Jean-François
Breau, Kevin McIntyre, George
Béliveau, "Salebarbes" rend
hommage entre autres à Doug
Kershaw en adaptatant
son "Louisiana Man" pour le
transformer en "Gagner sa vie".
♪♪♪
- Doug Kershaw d'abord, c'est
de la royauté, de la royauté
acadienne. Doug Kershaw, pour
ceux qui ne savent pas, ça a été
une légende... le premier invité
au Johnny Cash show.
♪ Allons danser
allons danser ♪
- Toujours avec son caractère
festif, "Salebarbe" reprend
aussi, avec ce deuxième album,
une chanson de Chuck Berry.
♪♪♪
ÉLOI PAINCHAUD
Membre du groupe "Salebarbes"
- Le premier, on voulait se
faire un beau petit feu puis
on avait du bois pour s'amuser,
bon, ça fait un feu. Mais là,
on s'aperçoit qu'on des canisses
de gaz.
(rires)
♪♪♪
- "Salebarbe" est inspiré par
le répertoire acadien et cajun,
mais aussi par la relève
musicale de l'est du pays.
- Nous autres, on voit
les jeunes puis on se dit :
heille! Les papies faut que...
faut qu'on se renouvelle.
Il faut qu'on se trouve
une façon d'être capable de se
bomber le torse puis d'avoir
une raison de le faire.
- On appelle ça la crise
de la quarantaine.
- L'album "Gin à l'eau salée"
est lancée ce soir sur Facebook
en direct du Vieux Treuil des
Îles-de-la-Madeleine.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.